le club méditerranée aurait dû
s'implanter ici en plein milieu du golfe
un golfe réputées de 27 trous les à
moliets les deux mois d'activités
estivales ont déjà laissé la place au
rythme lent des beaux jours de septembre
depuis 89 on entendait parler de ce
projet sans trop y croire peut-être trop
beau pour être vraiment vrai je ne pense
pas que ça portera tranche
niveau
aujourd'hui on est à peu près sûr on ne
verra rien venir ça ne changera pas
grand chose mais quand même un club med
dans ce village de 400 habitants la
haute saison et ses 15000 estivants on
va peut-être durer un peu plus longtemps
en réalité le club n'aurait été qu'une
partie d'un projet d'aménagement sur une
zac une zone d'aménagement concerté de
400 hectares gérés à 95% par la satel la
société d'aménagement du territoire
landais un organisme du département
ce projet comprenait en plus du club des
villes à un établissements balnéaires et
un vaste projet cher à françois
mitterrand de laboratoire international
de langue en tout 800 lits et 170
emplois dont un certain nombre créer sur
place nous avions des engagements de
monsieur trigano pour hangar pour
prendre
un certain nombre
de personnes si vous voulez dans la
population locale c'était ça qui était
important pour nous parce qu'après le
reste on sait très bien qu'il est un
ancien de fermer ma vie pas tout le
temps si vous allez au capital est comme
moi on y va tout le temps comme mika
année en sort pour aller faire un bon
repas dans un restaurant aujourd'hui
adieu les rêves de bonheur proposé à
moliets par le club reste les villas
elles ne dépendent pas de gilbert
trigano leur construction va donc
commencer prochainement et moliets
reprendra le développement de ses
projets touristiques comme si rien ne
s'était passé